an accord described as the Cornerstone
of European security is unraveling
Russia is finally withdrawing from the
treaty on conventional armed forces in
Europe in November NATO has condemned
the move but did the Treaty ever work
and what does this mean for Global Arms
Control this is Inside Story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program I'm
Muhammad Jim treaties are hard fought
and often take years to negotiate they
are designed to keep peace preventing
rival countries from going to war one
agreement signed in 1990 towards the end
of the Cold War is the treaty on
conventional armed forces in Europe the
United States other NATO members the
former Soviet Union and its eastern
European allies agreed to prevent
military buildup at their borders but in
recent years NATO's expansion towards
East and Russia's security interests
have left that Accord all but
meaningless now Moscow says it will
withdraw from the treaty in November
we'll explore the implications with our
guests in a moment but first this report
from Al jazeera's defense editor Alex
katopoulos
signed in 1990 towards the end of the
Cold War the treaty on conventional
forces in Europe or CFE was designed as
a confidence building measure between
NATO and what was then the Warsaw Pact
the main aim was to limit the amount of
Conventional Weapons in Europe from the
Atlantic Ocean to the Ural Mountains
NATO and the Warsaw Pact were each
limited to 20 000 tanks twenty thousand
pieces of heavy artillery six thousand
eight hundred combat aircraft and 2 000
attack helicopters
the numbers seemed staggering today but
at the time it was felt with
verification that this ceiling on
conventional arms in Europe would
prevent one side launching a sudden
attack on the other
the agreement was part of a series of
treaties designed to lower tensions
between the two blocks in a move towards
peace and relative stability
but with the breakup of the Soviet Union
and the dissolution of the Warsaw Pact
the gradual erosion of these Cold War
treaties along with NATO's rapid
expansion East left Russia increasingly
worried NATO was still being used to
contain it
even before the war in Ukraine Poland's
military was being bolstered with the
United States and other NATO members
beefing up their presence both in Poland
and the Baltic states
Friday's Announcement by Russia that it
would no longer comply with the treaty
is yet another sign of the dramatic
escalation intentions between NATO and
Russia Alex catopoulos for Inside Story
[Music]
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests in Fort Liberty North
Carolina is Peter elsav associate
professor of International Security
studies at the National Defense
University in Washington D.C
in Moscow is Pablo felgenhauer a defense
in Russian foreign policy analyst and in
Geneva is Samuel Romani associate fellow
at the Royal United Service Institute
and author of Putin's war on Ukraine a
warm welcome to you all thanks so much
for joining us today on Inside Story
Peter let me start with you today the
conventional armed forces in Europe
treaty which is an accord that's often
referred to as the Cornerstone of
European security it's unraveling so
what does this mean for Global Arms
Control
well it's a disaster but it was uh
completely expected first of all I would
like to say clarify I don't speak on um
behalf of the U.S government I work for
the government but I speak uh just
express my own views and I think it's a
disaster uh some of political analysts
now use this theory that we're coming
back to some kind of new medievalism uh
there's basically no treaties left and
um Ryan mittal is uh producing or arms
Galore that's a famous uh Jordan woman
company they're making tanks for Ukraine
now and their budget is increased by
hundreds of billions I believe 500
billion dollars uh for the defense
department for the Minister of Defense
uh in uh Germany
Russia has realized that this war has
turned into the conventional War like
everyone was speaking about the
importance of irregular or hybrid
Warfare now we have a conventional war
in Europe not seen or on the scale not
seen uh since uh World War II so we're
coming back in some sense to pre-World
War uh pre-World War one situation when
there are no rules no regulation no just
War Theory rules uh uh the Battle of
bakmud has been compared to the Battle
of uh Verdun of World War One this is uh
pretty much in a tuition War which of
both sides need a lot of conventional
arm this is a very frightening situation
I would say for the whole world Pavel so
Moscow says now that it will withdraw
from the CFE treaty in November is there
anything that could be done that would
convince Russia to return to the treaty
well the CFE is basic with that for a
long time uh Russia already withdrew
from the treaty in December 07 after a
half a year waiting period so now it's
just formally scrapping it but it's not
being uh complying for a very long time
the these treaties that ended the Cold
War opened Skies uh CFE others they
reflected the political reality in
Europe when the Cold War was over and
everyone was wanted to disarm build
confidence and these treatings were
built confidence to disarm to build
trust now there's no trust left there's
Armament instead of disarmament so the
treaties cannot be salvaged because the
political reality be reflected no more
no longer exists this is a different
world and it will require different
treaties maybe in the future to codify
and make more safe this more unsafe
world of conflict inside Europe
Samuel you heard Pablo there say that
the CFE has essentially uh been dead for
a long time
um President Putin suspended Russia's
participation in the CFE treaty in 2007
in 2015 Russia announced it was halting
participation in the treaty and now we
know that Russia is going to withdraw in
November has the treaty been effective
since 2007 or even 2015. has it been
dead all this time or was there some
cooperation going on at some level up
until now
well basically I mean the treaty that
nfcfe is actually been dying since 1999
when there was a debate about the
adapted CFE treaty and the Russians
ukrainians the belarusians the can
Kazakhstan joined that but the Russians
obviously wanted the whole of NATO
approach so all other NATO countries
should be able to consider regulating
their arms control uh and their arms
ourselves in the same way so it's been
dying since 1999 his death accelerated
after 2007 and then there was an
indefinite total withdrawal in March of
2015. so I don't think it's been really
effective I think that it's part of a
broader problem with the arms control
regime that we've seen affect new short
inspections as well as the death of the
INF trading but the treaties remaining
even even partially are normally in
effect created at least an atmosphere
for dialogue on arms regulation and also
on nuclear proliferation more broadly so
it may have had indirect or tangential
benefit for dialogue and cooperation I
don't think it's really been an
effective mechanism for a very long time
Peter earlier you were talking about the
dissolution of this treaty in very Stark
terms talking about very very dire
consequences
going forward I want to ask you from
your Vantage Point did the CFE treaty
ever really work and and why should
people have cared or not cared that it
was or wasn't working
well I agree with the previous uh
speaker in fact that it had some
symbolic significance that people were
talking to each other I'm sure sites
were not exactly following this uh or
treaties uh and violating them very
often and particularly in recent years
but like with the nuclear uh start a
treaty which was also abandoned in
February by Russia there was some
framework for discussion there is no
framework for discussion and
conversation at all now basically the
hands are completely open for this uh
proliferation a nuclear proliferation
and regular conventional arms uh so even
uh though it may have not worked in the
past uh really well there was some kind
of a system in place now there is
nothing left pretty much
Pablo obviously we can't have this
conversation without talking about the
war in Ukraine from your Vantage Point
how much did the war in Ukraine factor
into Russia's decision to fully withdraw
from the treaty
well the Russian policy foreign policy
began changing at Note 7 actually
dramatically there was this famous
Putin's address to the Munich security
conference and Russia turned from kind
of cooperation to the west to
confrontation if not directly but rather
slowly and solidly and the treaties that
were built on cooperation became
increasingly irrelevant as if if he was
a rather effective treaty when it was
signed tens of thousands of tanks and
other heavy Soviet equipment were moved
out of Europe into the Far East and in
Central Asia and into Siberia and also
that even when the Cold War ended and
the quotas of the CSE were no longer
much relevant it's very intrusive
on-site inspection regime was the main
feature especially for smaller European
nations that didn't have the
capabilities of the United States to
gather a raw Intel so as well this lady
was the main reason why Russia
actually moved out of the treaty to
prevent the on-site inspection there's
of course even the protocol still there
but that's not as intrusive and
effective so this trick is as the
conflict was prepared was being brewed
first with Georgia then with then Crimea
then Ukraine treaties and on-site
inspections became something that the
Russian military didn't want to see
because on-site around the sea actual
battle Readiness of units it's hard to
pick that up through satellite
ways the other treaties also disappeared
like the open Skies because Russia
wanted it Europe wanted it but America
didn't and the treaty is also dead I
mean there is no political back when
there's no political backbone for treaty
a treaty in itself cannot stand anymore
all right Pablo was mentioning some
other treaties that have disintegrated
over the years I want to step back for a
moment and take a look at some of the
other agreements that were meant to
strengthen Europe's security but are no
longer effective the open Skies treaty
permits unarmed reconnaissance flights
over member states as territory to
collect data on military forces and
activities it was signed in 1992 and
came into Force 10 years later but the
U.S withdrew in 2020 accusing Russia of
repeated violations Russia pulled out
the following year then there's the 2011
Vienna document an international
agreement on Military transparency in
2022 Russia refused to share data with
the other 56 members
now Samuel let me go to you this gradual
undoing of a group of interlocked
agreements and arms control treaties
um does that mean that the existing
security architecture in Europe is no
longer strong enough to ensure peace on
the continent
well I think it definitely is true that
that's the that's the case I mean the
existing European security architecture
has been dismantled one by one mostly
because of uh Russian unilateralism and
Russian obstructionism the Russians of
course would often claim that the West
was trying to tie Arms Control to other
political issues for example one of the
reasons why they claimed that NATO did
not ratify the adaptation of each treaty
was because Russia was maintaining uh
peacekeeping contingent in transistria
and also forces in Georgia as well as
committing atrocities in chechnya that
were unrelated to Arms Control so the
Russians will accuse the west of
basically uh tying that arms controls to
many other geopolitical conflicts and
making the Army control regime more
diluted but Russian obstructionism has
definitely played a part in the collapse
of the European security order
particularly when the Americans tried to
reach out to the Russians to have talks
in Cairo the Russians uh postpone that
nothing happened it's really really a
bad situation Peter let's talk about the
knock-on effect of all this I mean when
the rest of the world sees that these
treaties are unraveling what does it
mean for Global Security going forward
well as I've already said it's a pretty
disastrous situation uh there are
basically many centers in the world now
the Pentagon used to have this formula
four plus one uh there was uh China uh
Iran or Russia North Korea plus
non-state actors now it's really the
geopolitical situation there are new
Rising centers of power like turkey
India Pakistan Brazil so basically the
world is characterized by this uh
tremendous disbalance of power this is
uh the most critical situation I would
argue since the Cuban Missile Crisis and
so basically these centers of power can
act on their own militarily politically
and of course in terms of uh production
of arms and local conflicts we can see
the turkey in Russia now turkey in
theory I say emphasize in theory is a
NATO member but it's pretty much dealing
uh in a very friendly manner with Russia
uh dividing uh territories and spheres
of influence for example in Syria so and
uh many Rogue actors now will be able to
produce arms deal on their own like the
Wagner group is operating in Mali and uh
Central African Republic so basically
there are no rules anymore left and no
security agreements then there is a
global South which is uh quite
sympathetic or at least neutral towards
Russia on the war in Ukraine there are
there is some information that the
country like South Africa may be helping
militarily uh to Russia in the conflict
so I mean this is a very very Grim
situation I would say Pablo we spoke a
moment ago about the open Skies treaty
that was one example that we gave when
going through the history of some of
these treaties that have come apart
um when the U.S withdrew from the open
Skies treaty how was that perceived how
much did that decision ratchet up the
level of mistrust that we're now
witnessing between the U.S and Russia
well it did is not only between the US
and Russia between the U.S and Europe
because Europe very much wanted to have
open Skies they invested uh hundreds of
millions of dollars if you're keeping it
alive Germany was building a new plane
certified for open Skies Sweden had a
new plane Russia invested hundreds of
millions of those dollars to build two
Tuple left points certified for the
treaty and the United States said no
that's it and we're going out because
Congress didn't want to invest hundreds
of millions of dollars of building new
planes and build American planes were
Boeing 707s built in the beginning of
the 60s and they have been since cracked
after the U.S question treaty and
building new ones to get into that
American Pentagon didn't need because
open Skies used equipment that provided
not very accurate kind of images so but
that was important for European Papa
countries and for Russia we didn't have
the American
Recon capability that's in most likely
the best in the world so America was not
interested when Russia is not interested
in see if he the treaty goes
self-interest of different countries
rules right now uh the others will have
to just simply
do do what they can when the other
parties decide not to follow the rules
because the rules do not right now
reconcile with the political reality in
Europe and the world
Samuel it looked to me like you were
reacting to some of what Pavel was
saying there did you want to jump in
yeah well basically I wasn't really
particularly reacting to that but
obviously I think one of the other
points I want to bring up is that this
is not just an issue regarding NATO and
Russia regulating arms control the
United States has been trying to
basically Loop China into the global
Arms Control regime and China has said
fastly resisted that one of the efforts
that Mike Pompeo John Bolton many of the
senior officials in the Trump
Administration wanted to do would
actually have a renegotiation of new
start which would regulate the Chinese
nuclear Arsenal in the same way as the
Russians the Americans now the Russians
have usually sided with Beijing on that
and pointed the finger at British French
and NATO that nuclear arsenals as well
and finally there's also a clash between
Russia and many of the European security
institutions that it Still Remains a
member of Russia is out of the Council
of Europe but it's still part of the
osce but Russia has been clashing with
the osc repeatedly and reminding his
credibility accusing some of their
operatives of Espionage in the occupied
territories of Dinesh harassing them to
the point in which they have to withdraw
so this is a broader symptom at a
broader problem that stands well beyond
just arms control and other factors like
I just mentioned Peter I saw you nodding
along to some of what Samuel was saying
there do you want to jump in
yes I agree pretty much with the
sentiment that there is so much distrust
right now that I
um don't see basically like any
opportunity for any new treaties and
whatever I was uh saying about the start
of the new start uh that was very true
there was a sentiment on the side of the
Trump Administration that China kind of
was left outside of that and uh uh that
needed to be renegotiate it now we have
India and Pakistan the countries which
have nuclear weapons too so so basically
uh the hands are really open for all the
players to do pretty much whatever they
want but that political distrust uh has
never happened since even the Cold War
because even in the Cold War there was
first of all there were pretty much two
centers of power Moscow and Washington
and then after the Cuban Missile Crisis
there was a kind of a mutual respect and
understanding where the red line science
War now there are no red lines and in
terms of conventional arms this is a
really uh uh a conventional war on the
scale of World War One of World War II
going on in Europe right now so I mean
again I'm sorry I sound so pessimistic
but this is a very Grim situation if you
want to heal it actually Trump's uh
senior advisor on Eurasia in a very uh I
would say same person just recently said
that we are in the beginning of World
War III uh and I mean this is not an
optimistic situation with the with the
abandoning of basically all the treaties
right now Pablo Peter was talking about
the Cold War I I want to go back a ways
and ask you uh something you know from
the American point of view negotiations
over the CFE treaty were seen as
successful but I want to ask you about
what it was like from the Soviet
perspective was there a sense that
Gorbachev had given away too much ground
to Nato from the get-go
well yes I mean most likely for a bunch
of even didn't know in particular how
much weapons right the Russian military
Soviet military have stashed for the big
war in Europe
and so when the treaty was signed it
turned out that they had to
very quickly move enormous amounts of
Hardware away behind the euros and
Central through Asia into the Far East
and dump it there in the middle of
deserts or Taiga in Siberia so yes there
was a the Russian military were taken a
bit by surprise the Soviet military uh
by the terms that turned out when they
didn't even almost like the Kremlin how
many tanks they had and they had about a
hundred thousand not of course in Europe
but you know and most of them were in
the European part of Russia and in
Eastern Europe so that's was also of
course always a problem because
Communications between the Kremlin and
the military the Russian military always
well a bit of a problem
not always knows those matter their own
military have and are capable for and
makes the political mistakes like with
going into Ukraine and with the military
that turned out to be not very good for
the job but the war in Ukraine is going
to end Wars end there's going to be some
kind of Peace established and new
treaties will have to appear to keep the
situation Under Wraps a word that no one
needs in Europe apparently now no one
really is ready for it and so that means
I believe that the new
architecture of security and
Conventional Weapons in Europe will
appear after the Ukrainian conflict is
resolved Samuel I want to dig in a
little bit more into the the history and
the development of the CFE treaty over
the years there was an updated CFE
treaty that was drafted and approved in
Istanbul in 1999. that took into account
new reality such as the Warsaw Pact
dissolution as well as NATO expansion
but because NATO countries didn't ratify
that agreement President Putin suspended
Russia's participation in the CFE treaty
in 2007 then you have a 2015 Putin
essentially suspending their
participation in it if NATO countries
hadn't ratified the agreement why would
NATO expect Russia to adhere to its
obligations
well that's basically what the Russian
argument is is that the NATO countries
are tying at the regulation of the arms
control regime to other aspects of
Russian conduct there were also a couple
of other follow-ups that happened
afterward too there was a CFE 1A which
limited the American forces 250 000
troops that worked and that held
obviously there was a parallel and a
close timing obviously between 2007 with
this withdrawal and the Munich speech
which Vladimir Putin unveiled his
anti-western messaging and then the 2008
presidential elections which saw Putin
be replaced by Dimitri medvedia so I
think that Russian domestic politics
probably played a role in shaping some
of its critiques of the western handling
of CAF at that time but the Russians did
point to double standards with regards
to uh 1999 and also there's a tangential
issue but the violations of the CFE by
some smaller States in particular as the
bridge on have been noted and that
really hasn't been done much has been
done to slap them on the recital
uh Pablo treaty is like the ones we're
discussing how hard are they to put
together how hard fought are they and
how much effort does it take
well the conventional negotiations and
conventional forces in Europe that
formed the CFE began in a a long time
before they lasted all the 80s there was
talks and talks and they got nowhere at
all during the Cold War but when the
political atmosphere changed with
Gorbachev ending the Cold War together
with Reagan uh the technicalities that
were achieved during these Geneva
unsuccessful talks and conventional
forces allowed the CAC to be very
swiftly put together so when the
political atmosphere changes uh there's
capabilities and if there are
negotiations going on even on a
technical level that allows for Swift
movement forward when a political uh
atmosphere is good for that
and Pablo we only have one minute left
let me just ask you very quickly do you
expect given the geopolitical moment
that we are in right now so many crises
playing out concurrently do you expect
that we're going to just be seeing more
treaties unravel going forward
well there's not that many left already
so yes I mean right now we're in a
confrontational mode but again this war
will end and confrontation will be
besides NATO and Russia will have to
find the some kind of food pro quo some
kind of modus Revenge moving forward
that's inevitable
all right well we have run out of times
we're going to have to leave our
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests Peter elsov Papa felgan
Hower and Samuel Romani
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website Al jazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
Facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash AJ Inside Story you can
also join the conversation on Twitter
our handle is at AJ Inside Story for me
Muhammad the whole team here bye for now
foreign